nouvel accident fait revenir à 13 heures
vise gare de l'est un train de banlieue
pulvérisa butoir il y à un morts et 57
blessés comme il y à un mois gare de
lyon l'enquète porte sur les conditions
du freinage
le conducteur est formel les freins ont
lâché enfants soldats d'hier enfants
prostitués du bangladesh enfants
esclaves en inde la réalité des droits
des enfants et quelquefois sort vide
le nu la dénonce sans rien de leur mari
de plus 20 ans qu'une carte postale ou
un peu d'argent on les appelle les veufs
blanche
elles vivent en italie du sud ce sont
les fans de se les migrants qui sont
partis ailleurs chercher de quoi vivre
dans ce journal un reportage exclusif de
notre correspondant en italie marcel
trillât madame monsieur bonsoir il n'y a
certes pas de commune mesure mais
beaucoup diront encore un mois après la
catastrophe de la gare de lyon qui a
fait 56 morts
un nouvel accident début d'après midi
gare de l'est un train de banlieue qui
termine sa course bien au delà du butoir
enfin deux voies bilan un mort neuf
blessés graves
les 48 blessés légers françois corner
bernie mériaux et patrick diab et le
bruit des tronçonneuses et les sirènes
des ambulances dans un soleil d'été
un après-midi vacances à paris où il ne
devait rien se passer
il fait beau partout susurre depuis le
matin les bulletins météo et chacun 7
engourdi au fil des heures dans cette
bonne nouvelle rassurante et de saison
gare de l'est au bout de la voie 24 la
voiture de tête de la rames inox
château-thierry paris vient de se plier
contre des tampons du victoire de
percuter à une vingtaine de kilomètres
heure disent les témoins au bout du rail
le plan rouge a été déclenché une
dizaine de médecins réanimateurs des
infirmiers spécialisés du samu et de la
brigade des sapeurs pompiers de paris
sont sur place
désincarcéré brancarder vers les
ambulances et des moyens aériens
les blessés sont évacués vers les
hôpitaux six semaines après l'accident
de la gare de lyon qui avaient fait 56
morts et 32 blessés
le matériel est à nouveau dans une gare
parisienne est mise en cause une
nouvelle fois en accusation un défaut
effectivement du système de freinage
la ram ne s'est pas arrêté le conducteur
a essayé de prévenir ses passagers
on n'y avait rien mon sens que vous
voulez souffre et c'est pourquoi l'appel
afin d'y appuyer vous vous couchez et
mettez vous coucher on avait
l'impression que le train allait
s'arrêter normalement et puis on a reçu
un grand choc mois au départ je croyais
que c'était il y avait eu une explosion
quelque chose puisque on n'avait pas
l'impression d'aller très vite france et
vive et c'était vraiment la panique tout
on a coulé à la sorte si un client et je
suis descendu il ya deux trois personnes
qui sont complètement tout de suite est
venu sur le quai et il ya d'autres gens
qui ont précipité vous essayer de
l'aider à sortir les gens du wagon tel
un mort 57 blessées dont neuf grièvement
atteint le conducteur de la rame est
indemne et a pu répondre rapidement aux
enquêteurs le préfet de police jean
paolini a pu le rencontrer sur place
après cet accident
je ne peux pas vous dire exactement ce
qu'il a dit puisqu'une enquête est en
cours mais je peux vous dire que d'après
ses déclarations
c'est un accident qui est dû à une
défaillance mécanique
ce nouvel accident de train fait depuis
cet après midi l'objet de deux enquêtes
l'une interne à la sncf l'autre
judiciaire et policière sur place pierre
joxe a affirmé que le gouvernement
allait prendre les mesures pour
renforcer la sécurité du rail ont le
moment ce que je veux surtout souligner
c'est que ces problèmes de sécurité qui
met les familles à l'épreuve
il y a malheureusement beaucoup de
blessés et on déplore alors qu'il est un
décès est bien savoir que le
gouvernement se prépare à prendre toutes
les mesures destinées à accroître cette
sécurité
pour ce qui me concerne je constate que
les services de secours ont fonctionné
rapidement efficacement et je veux les
en remercier publiquement
cet accident de la gare de l'est en cet
après midi de vacances pense toujours la
même question
la technique évolue talent aussi vite
dans le domaine de la sécurité que dans
le domaine des performances les blessés
la sncf a mis à disposition un numéro de
téléphone le 40e 2 38 22 74 vous y
obtiendrez tous les renseignements sur
leur nom et sur le lieu éventuelle de
leur évacuation
le pourquoi donc maintenant une nouvelle
fois les conditions de freinage vont
faire l'objet de toute l'attention des
enquêteurs
essayons de faire le point patrick
esther et bien philippe la seule chose
que l'on puisse dire ce soir avec
certitude à la gare de l'est c'est qu'il
ya eu un problème de freinage maintenant
quel type de problème difficile à dire
actuellement les enquêteurs de
l'identité judiciaire et la justice
travaille derrière ces couvertures
rouges à l'intérieur même de la remorque
accidenté pour essayer de trouver le
maximum de preuves le maximum de traces
qui permettront d'expliquer ce qui s'est
produit alors on peut tenter d apporter
quand même trois hypothèses la première
c'est un problème de freinage total
difficile à dire difficile à expliquer
néanmoins c'était un peu le les mêmes
circonstances qui l'avaient amené à dire
qu'on ne peut pas avoir de preuves de
freinage et on en a apparemment calme
connus le 27 juin dans le dernier
accident il ya six semaines
deuxième hypothèse aprem de télécommande
en effet le conducteur se trouvait à
l'avant de l'arabe à l'intérieur d'une
remorque d'une voiture avec une
télécommande qui commandait donc les
ordres jusqu'à la motrice qui se
trouvait à l'arrière de la rame alors y
at il eu un problème de télécommande
entre les deux on ne sait pas on le sera
peut-être à l'issue de l'anc est enfin
troisième hypothèse qu'on ne peut pas
exclure non plus c'est une défaillance
du conducteur on sait que le conducteur
n'a pas connu de malaise parce que sans
ça en relâchant tous les systèmes la
motrice se serait arrêtée
automatiquement
alors le conducteur at il eu un moment
d'inattention quelques secondes parfois
suffisent à passer une situation normale
à une situation catastrophique
pourquoi la remorque a heurté aussi
violemment difficile à dire également
lorsqu'un butoir comme celui ci c'est
prévue en principe pour arrêter un train
qui est enfin de freinage et qui par
exemple à venir percuter à trois ou
quatre kilomètres heures maximum en
l'occurrence lorsqu'on constate que la
remorque est venu s'écraser s'est plié à
90° pratiquement en décollant d'un mètre
et demi au dessus des voies
c'est que la motrice en question avait
dû propulser l'arabe au moins jusqu'à 20
km heure au moment de l'impact pour
quelles raisons difficiles à lire
également réaction aussi tout à l'heure
de la cgt pour la centrale syndicale
c'est en quelque sorte la preuve par le
drame du bien fondé des critiques
qu'elles adressent la direction de la
sncf sur ses investissements
son concept de rentabilité et sur les
faibles moyens donnés à ses agents ce
que nous disons c'est que le matériel
n'est plus entretenue de la même manière
qu'ils y étaient par le passé du fait
notamment de la suppression des
effectifs
les révisions sont de plus en plus
longues
le matériel qui sort n'a pas forcément
la même qualité qu'il avait par le passé
est ce que vous mettez en cause les
cadences de travail je met effectivement
en cause les conditions de travail des
cheminots qui forcément se sont
dégradées avec la suppression de dix
mille emplois par an on peut imaginer
que c'est une erreur humaine aujourd'hui
je ne pense pas du tout à l'erreur
humaine aujourd'hui je pense plutôt à la
défaillance technique mais des enquêtes
sont en cours qui dirait sur ce dossier
nous attendons également une réaction de
monsieur delebarre le ministre des
transports qui devrait réagir sur les
mesures que compte prendre le
gouvernement
après ce nouvel accident qui met donc
une nouvelle fois en cause la sécurité
sur les lignes de banlieue sncf dans
l'actualité difficile de ce samedi 6 où
il nous faut également revenir sur la
route des vacances à nouveau meurtrière
la nuit dernière sur l'autoroute a10
paris bordeaux et sur la nationale 147
en haute-vienne deux accidents ont fait
sept morts et quatre blessés
quelques heures plus tôt le gouvernement
avait rappelé par télex à tous les
préfets
ces consignes de sécurité quitte pour
les représentants de l'état a les yeux
même sur le bord des routes suspendre le
permis de conduire des chauffards éric
perrin philippe montoise y tous les
préfets de france sur le pied de guerre
tel était le message du gouvernement
après l'hécatombe du week-end dernier
une fois les dispositifs habituels
renforcer les préfets étaient invités à
se rendre eux mêmes sur le terrain et à
procéder à des retraits de permis
immédiat en cas d'infractions graves une
mesure exceptionnelle justifiée par
l'inconscience de certains conducteurs
c'est une mesure efficace
je crois que l'efsf extrêmement
dissuasive car elle à son effet tout de
suite je sais bien que ça peut poser les
problèmes pour les intéressés mais je
crois que ils font il faut en user
dans les circonstances qui nous
paraissent grave c'est dans l'intérêt de
l'intéressé c'est dans l'intérêt des
usagers de la route et c'est dans
l'intérêt non une instruction expéditif
pour une sanction immédiate en présence
d'un représentant du préfet et d'un
membre de la commission administrative
de suspension du permis de conduire la
décision est prise sur-le-champ la
retraite permis mais dior c'est tout non
je ne pouvais que là vous ne pouvez pas
rentrer chez vous tout de suite je peux
pas rentrer chez moi je travaille huit
heures par jour avec mon véhicule je
peux plus travailler votre permis est
suspendu pour combien de temps
un retrait qui peut aller jusqu'à deux
mois dans ce cas l'automobiliste a dix
jours pour faire appel auprès du
tribunal administratif
en attendant il lui faut trouver
quelqu'un pour venir chercher son
véhicule sous réserve des derniers
arbitrages budgétaires la redevance
télévision devrait augmenter l'an
prochain il s'agit pour le gouvernement
de redonner au secteur public de
l'audiovisuel
comprenez antenne 2 et fr3 les moyens de
développer création française et qualité
dans un paysage audiovisuel de plus en
plus concurrentiel à l'étranger un chef
de campagne pour george bush le candidat
républicain dans la course à la maison
blanche distancée actuellement dans les
sondages par le démocrate joe khakis le
secrétaire américain au trésor james
baker a démissionné pour prendre ce
poste en 1981 déjà il avait contribué au
succès de ronald reagan
le président américain faisait tout à
l'heure les loges de baker un ami dit il
qui a réussi à fuir l'offensive et
imposer les réformes dans
l'administration à sa place
le président américain ne nomme le
banquier nicholas brady très réputé dans
les milieux d'affaires à wall street
négociations diplomatiques fructueuses à
new york l'irak ne met plus de
conditions un accord de cessez le feu
dans la guerre du golfe
l'arrêt des combats pourraient donc être
annoncée rapidement par le secrétaire
général de l'onu monsieur perez des
coûts et la genève c'est le sort de
l'afrique australe
que règle les négociateurs sud africain
angolais et cubains
là aussi il semble que les diplomates
que l'on voit ici à la fin d'une session
de discussions soient parvenus à un
accord de cessez-le-feu
il sera annoncé lundi dans les capitales
concernées pas en avant important pour
le médiateur américain
il pourrait préluder dans un prochain
round de discussions un compromis sur
l'accession à l'indépendance de la
namibie territoires administrés par
l'afrique du sud et sur le retrait des
quarante cinq mille soldats cubains
d'angola nouvelle conséquence de la
rupture décidé par le roi hussein entre
la jordanie et la cisjordanie occupée
par israël
amman le ministère des affaires des
territoires occupés et supprimer des
enfants du bengladesh vendus à des
tenanciers de bordel l'expression est
forte à la mesure peut être du dégoût
compte éprouver les fonctionnaires
internationaux de l'onu qui ont rendu
leur rapport sur l'esclavagé des enfants
dans le monde l'organisation
internationale il consacrera ses travaux
la semaine prochaine à genève au choix
le travail forcé l'enrôlement la
prostitution la vente au choix l'iran
l'inde le bangladesh pour les exemples
les plus difficiles
delphine de la selle pays où lover la
corruption et l'actualité que toi la
misère quotidienne enfants condamnée
sans espoir au travail forcé au crime et
à la prostitution
le rapport du groupe de travail sur
l'esclavagé est accablant il dénonce au
bangladesh au brésil ou en thaïlande
plusieurs milliers d'enfants à peine âgé
de 7 ans travaillent déjà dans les
maisons closes
aucun choix aucune liberté
nourris dans le meilleur des cas ils
sont battus si la recette n'est pas
bonne enfant abandonnées ou vendues pour
des sommes dérisoires
ils sont les victimes toutes désignées
pour le travail forcé parfois droguer
pour être plus productif
ils n'ont bien souvent aucun jour de
repos et ils ne sont pas soignés des
experts de l'onu l'ont constaté en inde
par exemple plus de 45 millions
d'enfants très jeunes travaillent dans
des conditions inhumaines l'esclavagé
pourtant pb il est même puni d'une
amende
environ 75 francs exploité à des fins
productives
les enfants sont aussi utilisés sur les
champs de bataille au moins douze pays
en guerre ont recours à de telles
pratiques
ils seraient environ 200000 âgés de 12 à
15 ans a porté les armes fanatisés en
iran ou victimes de rafles en
afghanistan go salvador ses enfants
soldats n'ont jamais connu que la poudre
et les bornes énumération de sévices en
tout genre dans ce rapport présenté à
l'onu la liste est longue trop longue
retour si vous le voulez un instant sur
l'accident gare de l'est qui a fait un
mort et 57 blessés je vous propose
d'écouter la réaction du ministre des
transports monsieur michel delebarre qui
s'est bien sûr rendu sur place
la fatalité n'a rien à voir dans ce
drame qui pose une nouvelle fois le
problème de la sécurité des transports
publics dont l'exigence cette exigence
de sécurité dans les transports publics
a été rappelé lors d'un récent conseil
des ministres le 20 juillet dernier par
monsieur le président de la république
comme ministre des transports et de la
mer je constate que les consignes de
sécurité données dès le mois de juillet
au conseil d'administration de la sncf
reste encore insuffisamment suivies
d'effet je demande nous demandons aux
responsables de la sncf de nous rendre
compte des mesures prises des nouvelles
dispositions à prendre
tirant les leçons de ces accidents dans
les plus brefs délais j'aurai dans la
soirée l'occasion de recevoir très
rapidement le président de la sncf pour
tirer avec lui un certain nombre
d'enseignements
nous aurons peut-être d'autres détails
sur cette entrevue entre le ministre des
transports et le président de la sncf
tout à l'heure dans le genre
de 23h que vous présentera bernard
pradines au retour à l'actualité nous
étions à l'étranger en 1 2 400 personnes
des pèlerins seraient mortes dans le
naufrage sur le gange d'un bateau bondé
maintenir la mémoire au japon il y à 43
ans hiroshima ce matin plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes
assistaient à une cérémonie
commémorative la bombe d'hiroshima qui
continue de tuer cette année sur le
monument au moment où ont été ajoutés
plus de 4000 noms ceux des victimes
décédées ces dernières années jacques
mirlin 1h et de colons mais un hymne à
la paix chanté par une chorale d'enfants
ont marqué ce matin la cérémonie
commémorative du 43e anniversaire du
bombardement d'hiroshima dans la ville
japonaise transformée en grande partie
au musée de l'horreur atomique
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes se sont recueillies en
souvenir du 6 août 1945
ce jour là à 8h15 un bombardier
américain lâche sur la ville cette bombe
la première bombe atomique qui les a
autant de conflits il en est aussitôt le
terrible 78000 150 morts quatorze mille
disparus près de dix mille blessés
graves
la décision d'utiliser les armes
atomiques qui avait été prise par le
président truman dont les troupes
sortait toujours deux millions de
soldats japonais
il faudra que le 8 août l'urss déclare
la guerre à l'empiré du soleil levant et
surtout que le 9 août une seconde bombe
atomique soit largué cette fois sur
nagasaki pour que le 14 août
enfin le japon capitule sans condition
vivre vingt ou trente ans loin de son
mari parti là-bas vers le nord et vers
un hypothétique travail des nouvelles
elles ont parfois quand il envoie une
carte ou un mandat c'est vrai en calabre
en italie du sud il y avait peu de
travail il ya vingt ans quand les hommes
sont partis alors elle ces femmes des
migrants sont restés pour les enfants et
pour tenir le foyer on les appelle les
veufs blanche
elles vivent à deux pas de chez nous en
italie du sud reportage exclusive sur
une autre phase de l'émigration
immigration marcel trillât - alors à je
te prends toi antonio pour époux et je
te promets d'être fidèle en toutes
circonstances
dans la joie ou le malheur dans la bonne
santé ou la maladie et de t'aimer de te
respecter pour toute la vie laura et
antonio en sont certains ils ne se
quitteront jamais et cette certitude
pour des jeunes mariés ici en calabre
c'est presque une nouveauté maria elle
aussi a connu cet instant de bonheur
sans mélange
le grand jour pour elle c'était il ya
trente ans dans sa mémoire
c'était hier elle a 55 ans elle a eu six
enfants
après son mariage elle a vécu ici
quelques années auprès de son mari et
aplatit au pied de la montagne en plein
coeur de la calabre depuis toujours le
travail manque d olivier quelques
maigres troupeau aucun emploi industriel
pour 3500 habitants vivent encore dans
le village plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'autres sont allés essaimé en
australie en argentine en allemagne ou à
milan dans l'autre italie celle du nord
celle qui nourrit son homme
beaucoup partait seul laissant leurs
femmes élever les enfants dans la
tradition calabraise sous le contrôle
étroit des anciens le mari de mariah
travail en allemagne depuis 21 ans
il revient une fois par an chaque mois
ils envoient deux mille fois maria
attend le prochain retour de son homme
c'est dans quelques jours j'ai dû
m'habituer
par la force des choses est lui aussi à
tant de sacrifices
pourquoi il fait ça pour le bien de
cette femme et de ses enfants mon mari
pour moi c'est la chose la plus grande
qui existent au monde parce que le
seigneur qui nous a unis pour nous aimer
mari et femme levé j'ai eu peur qu'ils
aient une autre vie en elle une autre
femme la femme doit rester à sa place à
dalle costaud mais l'homme moi ça ne
m'intéresse pas ce qu'il fait pourvu
qu'ils me voient l'argent pour faire
vivre les enfants les femmes doivent
faire attention
tandis que l'homme c'est pas pareil
non non vous n'avez pas de jalousie non
non non et lui non plus avec moi je
rencontrais un brave homme qui a
toujours travaillé pour sa famille et
elle remercie le bon dieu
maria a eu de la chance pour elle les
promesses du premier jour auront été
tenus envers et contre tout malgré la
déchirure de sa vie de femme catarina
croyais est elle aussi le jour de ses
noces que c'était pour la vie c'était en
1923 deux ans plus tard son mari est
parti tenter sa chance en argentine pour
faire face elle a dégagé tout ce qu'elle
avait au mont-de-piété ouvriers
agricoles comme elle son fils unique ne
l'a jamais quitté mais depuis 63 ans
elle n'a jamais revu son mari quand il
reviendra il me paieras ça moi mais
pourquoi vous n'avez pas pris un autre
mari quoi prendre un autre mari déjà que
l'autre m'est resté en travers de la
gorge à jésus marie un autre mari un
dieu me l'a envoyé est bon ou mauvais on
le prend comme il est on se débrouille
et recommencer avec un type comme vous
hassan ont abandonné ou non par leur
mari elles sont les reines dans les
maisons et dans le secret des petites
ruelles du village
seuls responsables de l'éducation des
enfants à condition de leur transmettre
la loi le pouvoir sans partage des
hommes sur cette société cramponné à son
passé au dessus du village l'aspro
monter la montagne ou la 'ndrangheta la
mafia calabraise cachent les victimes de
ces rapts en attendant le paiement des
milliards exigés en rançon l'une des
rares sources de revenus de cette région
abandonnée toute la journée sur la rue
principale les émigrés à la retraite et
ceux qui ne sont jamais partis roi sans
divertissement d'un royaume sans avenir
parmi eux antonio un revenant de
l'émigration entrer au pays en 1983 les
reins rongé par les vapeurs d'acide dans
une fonderie allemande pour sa femme
elisabetta le temps des grandes
illusions a duré 15 jours
et puis 22 ans seule avec ses quatre
enfants antonion revenait une fois par
an mais chaque mois il envoyait sa
feuille de paye et son salaire et il
devait justifier ses dépenses
personnelles sa manière à elle de sauver
son ménage
envers et contre tout écrivez il
téléphonait lélex au moins personnel et
même on se disputait par lettre mari et
femme
c'était des bellens a disputé quelques
temps je réunissais je l'écrivais plus
alors lui il se dépêchait d'écrire pour
moi ces femmes sont des victimes
ce sont des femmes qui sont incapables
de comment dit-on de fermeté parce que
selon moi elles devraient cesser vivre
leur mari voilà comment vous voyez votre
vie ce soir
ce soir je la vois éblouissante je suis
très ému je ne sais pas c'est en calabre
c'est en italie du sud 17 aussi dans le
sud de l'europe en sport le grand prix
de budapest de formule 1 de hongrie
prost n'a pas confirmé son meilleur
temps d'hier il sera septième sur la
ligne de départ c'est son compère le
brésilien sénat sur l'autre mclaren
aimant seul le britannique sur williams
qui ont raflé la pole position
patrick naud
plus une minute avant la fin de la
dernière séance d'essais ultime
tentative d'alain prost pour s'adjuger
la pole position du grand prix de
hongrie le 10e de la saison circuit
étroit et sinueux où il est très
difficile de dépasser la pole est ici
presque un passeport pour la victoire et
ce passeport c'est une fois de plus
ayrton senna qu'il a en poche grâce à un
temps canon regardez prost à l'attack il
est gêné par les européens de la rouerie
et modena il doit se contenter de la
4ème ligne seulement avec le septième
temps
loin derrière senna qui occupera demain
la pole position la huitième du
brésilien cette saison 2e temps des
essais mhand seul trahi par la mécanique
ici même l'an dernier il veut sa
revanche et la williams que rivaliser
avec les turbo sur le tourniquet
hongrois tout comme la forte de thierry
boutsen troisième temps aujourd'hui
demain la puissance ne sera pas
forcément un atout sur cette piste très
glissant sénat en a encore fait
l'expérience cet après midi et s'il est
en première ligne
ce sera l'un des rares grands pays où
les atmosphérique aux routes leur chance
d'ailleurs sur la grille il y en aura
cinq entre senna et prost prost bien mal
placé pour rejoindre senna au nombre des
victoires cette saison
natation dans le championnat de france à
dunkerque eux noté les nouveaux records
de france du tourangeau christophe
bordeaux 400 m 4 nages en 4 minutes 23
secondes et 75 centièmes record de
france également au 100 m dos record de
franck schott en 57 secondes et 63
centièmes le tiercé cet après midi
c'était à deux villes combinaison
gagnante de 4 17 15 pour 5 francs elle
rapporte dans l'ordre 7945 francs 50
dans un ordre différent 823 francs 50 le
quarté + 4 17 15 9 pour 6 francs dans
l'ordre 162 1534 francs 60 centimes dans
un ordre différent 8418 francs le plus
trio 205 francs 80 demain dimanche c'est
tout 1988 prix du casino de deauville 20
partants voici les pronostics du de
pierrette brès pierrette brès pronostics
9 5 14 7 4 11 13 et 16 fin de ce journal
prochain rendez-vous d'information c'est
à 23 heures dans un instant vous avez
rendez vous avec sophie davant pour
toujours un chaud soleil excellente
soirée à tous sur antenne 2